hello everyone
it's mid-january 2022.
i wrote a column this week for one of
canada's major newspapers the national
post
and i thought i'd read it for those of
you who want to watch or listen
it's entitled
time to live again
i spent more than three hours on the
phone last weekend trying to get through
to the online security department of one
of canada's major banks
one of my accounts was shut down
because i had the affrontery to sign in
from alberta an event too unexpected for
the bank's security systems i was placed
on hold interminably
subjected all the while to the corporate
world's idea of music
to soothe me
i was then offered a call back which i
duly received 45 minutes later
then i was placed on hold again
and again
this all occurred after my patients had
already been exhausted in the aftermath
of trying to fly in canada
like so many canadians i have been
unable to see many of the people i love
and who are tolerant enough to return
the sentiment for nearly two years
lockdowns restrictions
limits on personal and social gatherings
precautions precautions
precautions
but everything had opened up enough in
principle so flights for such purposes
were in principle once again possible my
wife and i therefore took the
opportunity on the last day of 2021 to
fly first to comox british columbia and
then several days later to our joint
home town of fairview alberta
however the airline we had arranged our
flights with canceled slash delayed all
six flights we had scheduled
furthermore they had no staff available
in one entire wing of edmonton's airport
this made rescheduling prohibitively
difficult
we were delayed by one full day
traveling to british columbia and then
another day traveling to alberta and
there were further delays on our way
home to toronto
this took quite a chunk out of an eight
day trip
all this from an airline that not so
long ago was a model of efficiency
like most people in canada and in the
broader western world my wife and i are
accustomed to systems that work
when we booked flights in the past with
rare exceptions we arrived safely and on
time
when we used our banking systems online
we gained access to our accounts
when we had to phone security because of
a login problem we were able to talk to
someone who was able to help
and because we were spoiled westerners
we expected that such would always and
consistently be the case
why
because by and large our systems worked
miraculously well
the power
and the heat it's 40 below here in
northern alberta and has been for three
weeks
always worked
planes took off and landed on time banks
were open and effective and honest
but there are empty shelves in the
grocery stores here in fairview the
supply chains that provide our food just
in time are severely stressed
while i was here i spoke with a local
restaurateur who operates the pizza
place i worked in 40 years ago
she is barely hanging on
this is true of most local businesses
i was on the phone for three hours
trying to sort out a minor banking issue
after being delayed for a full day while
flying
after having been delayed in a similar
way only four days before
and because i'm an entitled westerner
accustomed to my privileges i got whiny
about it i have a banker that takes care
of my affairs and i sent him and his
associate a string of complaints about
the service i was receiving
they wrote back apologetically and told
me that they're barely able to function
with the covid restrictions the
attendant staff shortages also caused by
illness and their inability to attract
new employees a problem besetting many
industries at the moment
i am not accustomed to feeling
particularly sympathetic for the
travails of large successful enterprises
banks airlines utilities and the like i
expect a certain standard of service so
that i can conduct my own affairs
effectively and am impatient when delays
unnecessary in the normal course of
things emerge
the letter from the bank stopped me and
made me think however
it wasn't just the bank
it was also the airline
it was the empty shelves in the grocery
store in northern alberta it was the
daughter of the man i once worked for as
a cook back when i was a teenager it was
the shopkeepers and small business
people i have spoken with on this trip
we are pushing the complex systems upon
which we depend and which are
miraculously effective and efficient in
their often thankless operation to the
breaking point
can you think of anything more unlikely
than the fact that we can get instant
trouble-free access to our money online
using systems that are virtually graft
and corruption free
just imagine how much work trust and
efficiency was and is necessary to make
that a reality
can you think of anything more unlikely
than fast reliable and inexpensive jet
air travel nationally and
internationally
in absolute safety
or the constant provision of almost
every consumer good imaginable in the
midst of plentiful varied and
inexpensive food
these systems are now shaking
we're compromising them seriously with
this unending and unpredictable stream
of restrictions lockdowns regulations
and curfews
we're also undermining our entire
monetary system with the provision of
unending large guests from government
coffers to ease the stress of covid
response
we're playing with fire
we've demolished two christmas seasons
in a row
life is short these are rare occasions
we're stopping kids from attending
school
we're sowing mistrust in our
institutions in a seriously dangerous
manner
we're frightening people to make them
comply
we're producing bureaucratic
institutions that hypothetically hold
public health in the highest regard
but subordinating all our properly
political institutions to that end
because we lack leadership
and rely on ultimately unreliable
opinion polls to govern broad-scale
policy at the political level
i've never seen breakdown in
institutional trust on this scale before
in my lifetime
i was recently in nashville tennessee no
lockdowns
no masks no coveted regulations to speak
of people are going about their lives
why can that be the case in tennessee
and in other u.s states such as florida
when there are curfews
curfews
in quebec two years after the pandemic
started with a vaccination rate of
nearly 80 percent
when bc is still limiting social
gatherings
when we are putting tremendous and
unsustainable strain on all the complex
systems that have served us so well and
made us so comfortable in the midst of
the troubles of our lives
the cure has become worse than the
disease
i have recently spoken with senior
advisors to provincial governments in
canada
there is no end game in sight
the idea that canadian policy is or
should be governed by the science is not
only not true
it's also not possible as there is no
simple pathway from the facts of science
to the complexities of policy
we are deciding by opinion poll to live
in fear and to become increasingly
authoritarian in response to that fear
that's a danger too
and it's increasingly real
how long are we going to flail about
hiding behind our masks afraid to send
our children who are in no danger more
serious than risk of the flu to school
charging university students full
tuition for 10th rate online education
pitting family member against family
member over vaccine policy and
most seriously compromising the great
economic engine upon which our health
also depends
until we decide not to
there are no risk-free paths forward
there's only one risk
or another pick your poison that's the
choice life offers
i am weary of living under the
increasingly authoritarian dictates of a
polity hyper concerned with one risk and
oblivious to all others
and things are shaking
around
us enough canadians enough canadian
politicos enough masks enough social
gathering limitations enough restaurant
closures enough undermining of political
and social trust
make the bloody vaccines available to
those who want them quit using force to
ensure compliance on the part of those
who don't
some of the latter might be crazy but by
and large they're no crazier than the
rest of us set a date
open the damn country back up
before we wreck something we can't fix